i was working with the people who were
designing the next version of gmail and
you know i found myself in the room with
you know the designers who manage this
interface where people i mean you go to
any internet cafe
back before covid and you see almost
every laptop has this like gmail
page open right i mean almost everywhere
oh yeah we all know it sure we all know
like people live in this space it's a
habitat it's not just a product we use
it's a space we
we live and we work in and given that
importance i thought to myself you know
as we're designing the next version of
this this is an opportunity to really
think about
how this is an enormous source of stress
in people's lives you know
it's funny because i think one of the
responses to the film when i say
in the film that i'm really addicted to
my email a lot of people don't
understand that because emails sort of
just junk mail for for a lot of people
but coming from
i think the the generation that you came
from and that i came from email
is a central place where especially at
the time every now and then i would be
getting um
you know big introductions to people who
would help us advance the work so it
became my own slot machine to check you
know is did daniel kahneman the head of
you know the founder of behavioral
economics email me and
that kind of thing but that said we know
i was thinking about
uh is gmail really good for people
i was thinking about you know this is a
pretty addictive
stressful place in people's lives could
we reduce social expectations could you
make it so that when you send an email
you could say
hey i actually don't need a response for
two weeks could we start to implement
features that would reduce the
addictiveness
and you know there i am in the room and
there's no other room in the world
besides that gmail design team room and
if i thought of the room
where it happened and i thought if there
was any room where people would care
about this
this would be the one and i found to no
disparagement of my colleagues who were
working at the time i just didn't find
the conversation
really as thoughtful as it needed to be
given the consequences that we were
having for like six hours or four hours
of people's days
so first how many people were in that
room
good question i think probably somewhere
between six to ten people
usually in those rooms okay how long
were you at google before
uh the this uh this discussion is
happening
um so within about three months we had
joined the gmail team and we're starting
to have those conversations so pretty
three to four months i was in there and
then you sent out a now legendary
deck around hey we should probably be
thinking more
deeply about the uh choices we're making
because they're about to influence
billions of people
over time uh what was was that um
just months after you joined google yeah
that was in
january of one year in so basically one
year into being at google after trying
to make it work with the gmail team
you know i really did i really wanted to
see us ship
something that would make a dramatic
positive impact in people's mental
health around
email and stress and notifications and
attention
and um because it wasn't going anywhere
and because
overall like other apps whether it was
quora or path or all the you know
instagram at the time which was just you
know blowing up
um i was just disappointed in where are
we as a tech industry heading like what
where have we lost our moral compass do
we really care
about what we're building and how it's
impacting people or have we kind of
forgotten um you know that there's more
to just capturing lots of attention and
going getting virality
and so i i started um i went on a trip
to the santa cruz mountains with my
um one of my best friends azza raskin
who um his father jeff raskin invented
the macintosh project at apple
and that's where we get our name um in
humane for the center for humane
technology
aza's father jeff wrote a classic book
called the humane interface which is the
foundation of some of our work
but aza and i were in the santa cruz
mountains and
you know connecting with nature and just
being out there and it just really
struck me that i needed to go back
and there needed to be something that
was said about this and it the words
came to me and that trip and it was
never before in history
have a handful of technology designers
who mostly look like
you know hipster engineers in san
francisco between 25 35 years old
mostly men mostly white you know making
decisions on behalf
of a billion people was the number of
the time now it's three billion people
um to show you the growth rate of how
fast these things go
and the presentation included just a
bunch of examples you can actually find
it online on
minimizeddistraction.com i think is
where someone had leaked it and posted
it
but it used a bunch of examples of how
technology's
tapping into our psychological
vulnerabilities
and the cost that it was having on kids
on mental health
and it ended up going viral i sent it to
a few people
for feedback and instead of the 10
people i sent it to exclusively
i came to work the next day and i had
like 100 emails about it
so i knew it had gone viral to many more
people and
as the film the social dilemma says you
know it went up to larry page's office
and several different meetings that day
and i think it created a moment of
reckoning where we actually said hey can
we do something about this
and i would host follow on lunches at
google bringing people together from
different teams to talk about it
but it was just hard to get a real
coordinated action because the
external global pressure from consumers
or from the world or from governments
just wasn't there and that's what's
astonishing is to see where it is now
because compared to you know lunchroom
meetings that i would book at a random
part of the google campus with you know
12 people showing up saying how do we
fix
this to today where you have i think
something like 30 to 40 million people
are going to have seen this film very
soon
in 190 countries it feels like it's
taken eight years to get to a point
where we're gonna
be able to meaningfully change these
incentives
so this is 2012 that you uh
send this deck out and then it goes
viral like google yeah
2012 to 2013 somewhere around there
beginning end of 2012 early 2013.
all right let's call it uh early 2013
then um
so when you send this deck out to your
10 contacts
um were you concerned at all that this
is going to make you seem like
uh someone who is not on board with like
the
like the general direction of uh
development of uh the project you're on
i mean you're relatively new to the
company it's an enormous company um
and the rest of it like is there any
concern that is going to be bad for your
career
yeah i'm glad you're bringing this up
because it's easy to skim past this now
i was i actually had no idea how people
were going to respond i was prepared
that
if i had gotten fired for some reason
because of it that i would be okay with
that so i i had pre-committed that that
was an okay thing
an okay outcome for me um and
i was you know i was actually really
afraid
to send it out which is why it was
surprised me when so many people
um when it shared virally i mean you
know on google slides you can click
on a presentation it shows you in the
top right hand corner how many
simultaneous
viewers there are and there was
something like 150 and then later that
day like 400 simultaneous
viewers you know in a 10 000 you know
whatever it was
20 000 person company back then so
uh i did not expect to be i never been
in my life a person who went against the
grain who was highly disagreeable who
was
trying to challenge things i wasn't
outspoken it just struck me that
no one was sufficiently paying attention
to this and it was too important not to
um so then
it sounds like the feedback was by and
large quite positive so much so that
they actually give you this new title
and role saying you're going to be our
our new design ethicist you're going to
tell us what's what
um so how how was that transition and
role
and how long were you in that role yeah
so this is important i
there was a fellow at the google
creative lab in new york who had
actually helped co-write to make this
the story all circular he helped
co-write the first macintosh
uh the famous macintosh super bowl ad if
you remember the woman
running down the streets and throwing
the hammer and smashing the big brother
screen
he had co-written that advertisement
and he had seen this presentation at
google
and was really impressed by it we
connected on um
uh this this book that had really shaped
him by neil postman called amusing
ourselves to death
uh which is really i think entirely
descriptive
of exactly everything that's going wrong
right now that
culture and our society would surrender
to the forces of technology
and technology would become would start
to subsume
culture and remake culture in its image
and that we would be caught in this kind
of race not for attention didn't express
it that way
but this race to make things amenable to
how technology would want to see and
shape the world metrics like
you know in this case he was talking
about sat scores and predictive
analytics for college admissions and
things like that
but he didn't at the time know about a
few years later we'd have tech companies
running by the metrics of
time spent and engagement and that book
i'm using ourselves to death
um opens with this description that we
were all watching out for the year 1984
when the form of dystopia and tyranny in
the form of big brother
and the orwellian vision of dystopia
would come to you know subsume society
and then luckily it didn't come to pass
we
made it through 1984 and that didn't
happen but he says that there was always
this second vision of dystopia that was
the more subtle one that people don't
remember as much which is aldous
huxley's brave new world
where the tyranny is not of restricting
access to information or censoring what
you can
or can't think but instead bludgeoning
people
with a sea of irrelevance with so much
narcissism and egoism and passivity and
informational
overwhelm that people wouldn't know
what's true and they'd be amusing
themselves to death
and this was the book that this fellow
at google
who offered to host me to work on this
problem
and i connected on and then i started to
become i didn't know what to call it so
we just said let's call it design ethics
and no one had ever thought how do you
ethically design
along the social psychological
vulnerabilities of humanity
and it became more of a research project
for the first
two years and i tried changing various
things within google we tried talking to
the android team
and changing things on chrome and how
would we make smartphones work
differently and talk to the app store
teams about changing incentives
but um i couldn't get anywhere and so
about three years
later um i decided to leave and
soon after that i was on the sam harris
podcast where um
you and i i think both launched our
careers in a certain sense
and yeah harris thank you thanks to sam
that podcast was the kind of coming out
moment for this work
and chris anderson who runs ted emailed
me
a few days later which was i think only
three days before the ted conference
and said i need to get you to come to
ted to do a ted talk on what you just
shared on sam's podcast and um
i was actually about to fly to czech
republic with my mother who was dying at
the time and this was the last time that
we were going to take a trip
abroad and i decided to go but then cut
my trip short
go to ted had two days to prepare this
first ted talk on how technology
controls a billion minds
and that's where i met you um i remember
the moment it happened at the
you know the buffet table i think on
that friday um and um
yeah that was it's a long time ago now
well i
i did not know what the run-up was to
you know for me i was just blown away by
your talk and was like this that was
incredible
that's like um so hearing like i didn't
know about sam and um
certainly not um uh you know you're
abbreviating your trip with your mom um
so when you decide to leave google
here's the thing
google famous for its food famous for
all this stuff
you're hanging out there you've got this
design ethicist job and you're like hey
android try and do something better hey
crow you know like everyone trying to do
something better and you realize you're
not making headway
i still feel like 99 of people would
have been like
just stay there forever do your thing
because you're in like corporate womb
like you know people
respect you uh you're still in the
mothership
um so it feels like a big decision to be
like all right this is now working it's
time for me to go particularly when
when you decided to leave um it didn't
seem like it was clear what the next
steps would be
you know it's so interesting and i
really appreciate you asking these
questions uh uh
it that's exactly right i did not at all
feel clear
you know leave and go do what like how
you're inside of the biggest
most influential company in the world
that is probably one of the biggest
surface areas for
these problems showing up which is all
of android which actually has a majority
of smartphone users around the world in
the us
obviously it's more iphone skewed um why
in the world would you leave
that environment and obviously be paid i
think nicholas nassim telep
wrote the line that the three most
addictive things in the world are
cocaine
heroin and a monthly paycheck it's very
hard to walk away from
you know monthly security uh job
security
and i really didn't know how we would
ever change
these problems i i remember
feeling deep anxiety about what it would
mean to leave and not
and live off my savings frankly and
figure out what how in the world what do
you do to sort of get
people to care about something in a
public stage
and there was about a year and a half
after that
um where nothing happened and it was
when
i think trump got elected and the
election took place and the conversation
started happening about
russian manipulation of the elections
and i had seen
certain things like this myself and had
been part of a community of researchers
who'd been tracking
some of those manipulations that i
decided i had to jump in full steam
into into this problem even if i didn't
know how we would
i would get the you know get the
attention it deserved thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you